hey here's something kind of I don't
know that that it's funny but it's
certainly interesting
somehow uh Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker managed to do
another press event and at this event he
was joined by Republican Senators Tom
Cotton and Rick Scott two horrible
people
Walker did his normal routine where he
tells unintelligible stories in an
incoherent way and you can visibly see
cotton and uh Scott cringing where they
clearly seem to be thinking what the
hell am I doing here I don't know who
thinks these events are good ideas here
is Herschel Walker railing against
pronouns
um I'm going to take a position against
adverbs if I ever run for something but
Walker focused on pronouns and just look
at the looks on cotton and Scott's faces
trying to act as though this is normal
when they clearly know it is not hey
just think about it pronoun in our
military
how do you identify in our military This
Is War times what happened to push-ups
sit-ups because I can tell you right now
China I ran to Russia not talking about
pronouns right Tom Cotton looking
particularly pained as this is going on
here is another one of Herschel Walker's
great stories about a bear and a dog and
something about how he's responding to
the abortion scandal
they'll do whatever it takes or say
whatever they have to say because they
want this seat right here
but I don't think they know that they
woke up a bear right
hey I'm not just a dog now I'm a bear
yeah and I got a couple email from some
of our viewers in the LGBT community
saying does he understand what bears are
in the LGBT community I'm sure he
doesn't uh uh and then last clip here
Herschel Walker again tries telling the
story
about the Bulls and the cows in the
field every time he tells the story the
story is different and again here Rick
Scott looking particularly demoralized
at having to stand up there
as they've been saying something is
better somewhere else and I'm here to
tell you it's not so I've been telling
this little story about this bull out in
the field with six cows right and three
of them are pregnant
so you know he got something going on
but all he cared about is kept his nose
against the fence looking at three other
cows have been blown to him
now all he had to do is eat grass but no
no no he thought something was better
somewhere else so he decided I want to
get over there so one day he measured
that fence up
and you say I think I can jump this
so that they came where he got back and
he got back and as he took off running
he Dove over that fence and his belly
got cut up onto the bottom
but as he made it over on the other side
he shook it off and got so excited about
it and he ran to the top of that hill
but when he got up there he realized
they were Bulls too
so what I'm telling you
don't think something is better
somewhere I think that maybe this is a
version of a bird in the hand is worth
two in the bush or the grass isn't
really greener on the other side or
something like that so of course as I've
been telling you we are very closely
monitoring the polling data and it is
still quite tight we have a couple of
new poles uh Walker versus Warnock
Rafael Warnock is now winning by an
average of 3.3 there is a new Trafalgar
pole that basically has this even with
Warnock plus one as insane as it is this
guy should be losing by 50. Walker
he's still in the race and so it is
going to take more to knock this guy out
of the race it will probably go until
the last minute on Election Day
But continuing to humiliate himself and
who thinks these press conferences are
good ideas we'll take a quick break and
be back after this yes right-wing media
fell for a black lives matter antifa
hoax we will talk about it next
plastic is everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year but you can help make a
change our sponsor hold on makes trash
and kitchen bags that are heavy duty
plant-based non-toxic and 100 home
compostable which means they break down
in weeks rather than decades they don't
fill up our landfills they don't pollute
our oceans they're zip seal kitchen bags
come in sandwich or gallon bag sizes to
fit your needs and the best part about
hold on bags is they work I use them at
home they're just as good as all of the
name brand bags you fill them up they
stretch and they don't break everybody
uses trash bags and freezer bags if you
care about the planet you can do
something by using hold on bags instead
and it's a really easy way to do your
part to shop plant-based bags and
replace single-use Plastics all over
your home go to hold on bags.com and
you'll save twenty percent with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below